hello it's the worst way to start hi hey
my name is Rory Scovel and I oftentimes
peruse on the youtubes what do you wipe
in the windows Wow look at that I was
introduced to one video when I was
playing in Denver with Nick Thune we
came across the video look at this car
you know what I see a car like this
first thing I do is I say what y'all
look at that it's essentially a guy
continually saying would you look at
this would you look at that and he's
just doing it over and over again what
you look at that Chuck look at that I
can't pull it out either I'd have to
drill it on it and you can see even the
other guy not really knowing like why is
this guy talking like this but he's so
good at selling it and not breaking when
he starts talking about going to court
and like ripping up a ticket it like
takes it to another level
whenever a cop right the on a ticket the
first thing you do is you take the
ticket and you say what y'all look at
this you know what I mean I'm also a
pretty big Pink Floyd fan I like all of
their music but sometimes to remind
myself of how good they are at their own
music there's one YouTube video it is
called worst band ever butchers Pink
Floyd
is a really bad and it is five guys
playing comfortably numb' in front of I
assume a music store
[Music]
think about how horrific that would be
for the music store to have to think
listen to that
and the singing is so bad the playing is
so bad the pace the rhythm all of it is
off but I will say these guys go
straight through the entire song the
added bonus of it is the viewer getting
the question do they know that it's bad
there's a video called Christmas tree
cat that I've watched a lot you are so
bad you watch it you almost wonder why I
mean it is funny but there's almost two
things you're getting there you're one
you're getting a cat but look on the
cat's face it's like I don't even give a
[ __ ] it almost looks like the cat is
like I am done with you Cheryl she seems
like a person who just got a camcorder
she's using a VHS full camcorder zooming
in and out like just saying that the cat
is bad it almost makes you feel good
that you kind of wish life could just be
that easy you are so bad when I was a
kid maybe like a lot of people I used to
watch like Larry Bird Magic Johnson and
Michael Jordan I have vague memories of
all those amazing highlights but there
is one that I do remember specifically
watching at home when Michael Jordan
gets the pass at the top of the key and
he's going to dunk the basketball and
then he pulls it down like two Lakers
jumped beside him and he does the lamb
everyone has seen the shot everybody
like knows the shot but for someone who
didn't even watch basketball all the
time died actually saw a pretty
monumental shot by one of the greatest
players of all time it's not even funny
it's just nostalgic so those are my
videos that I like watching on YouTube
check them out you will spiral into a
rabbit hole for sure I'm watching other
weird funny videos but thanks so much
mames Rory Scovel if you haven't seen it
it is you won't be able to get very far
in it
you are like today what do they think of
themselves